we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine to david p let's take a
listen to a voicemail that came in last
night hey David I've been paying
attention to a lot of the talk about
Hillary Clinton's health and whatnot and
happen to see that video uh where her
Secret Service agents like caught her
before she fell yeah trying to enter
that ban on 911 so just wondering if you
would be able to tell us what the likely
uh likelihood of events would be if
Hillary Clinton was a 26 to actually run
for president like I didn't know if they
would turn to Bernie and that case or if
they would you know still try to make it
worth work with Hillary or possibly they
would look at Biden and be like hey man
we gotta get some establishment Democrat
in here so yeah I'll just wondering what
you thought about that Thanks I don't
think it's going to happen uh I I've
already started getting emails from
people saying hey you've gotta go to
Bernie you can't go to Joe Biden if
Hillary's out for health because
Bernie's the guy who actually has
delegates and another saying no no
you've got to go to Biden because he's
really the guy who's well positioned to
actually uh come in and take this thing
over another saying well we've already
we would if Hillary were president and
she had a health issue it would go to
Tim Kaine so really if Hillary has to
bow out for health reasons it should go
to Tim Kaine my answer is Hillary is not
leaving this race due to health issues
or anything else it's just not going to
happen so I I believe that it will be a
moot point in the end on the bonus show
today I have been talking for a while
about how the sugar industries PR has
done some really horrible things and
we're going to talk about that on the
bonus show today we also have a new
report about very specifically what jobs
are going to be eliminated in the next
five years due to artificial
intelligence and much more it's a great
bonus show today david pakman.com slash
membership is how you sign up instantly
and get instant access